bailey how are you this morning i am
good john how are you
so good so good so how can i help this
morning
yeah thank you for taking my call so me
and my husband moved back to our
hometown
after an unplanned pregnancy in to look
closer to family for help
okay but my question is deciding whether
we should live in our hometown for the
rest of our life and raise our family or
maybe actually move
again to get a little space from family
so my guess is you're asking that
because you want to get a little space
from family
yeah i mean i love them and appreciate
them
but uh both of our parents are divorced
so we have four sets of grandparents
and now we're in very close proximity to
three of them and it just gets to be
overwhelming
and i love them so when i say this i
don't want to sound negative but
we don't want the life our parents had i
don't know how to say that without
they're not bad people i just we want to
we have different values for our
marriage and sometimes i don't know if
it's the healthiest to live around them
hey hey bailey can i stop you there for
a second yes go ahead
don't apologize for that you know what
that makes you
that makes you an absolute gangster
one of um the the
therapy researchers who i love terrence
real
says that family trauma burns through a
family tree
like a forest fire until somebody has
the courage to turn and face it
and that's what you and your husband are
doing and so what you are doing
is generational work it is legacy work
you are literally making your family
tree different
because of the hard hard choices you're
making so never
um don't beat yourself up for wanting a
different life to what your parents had
yeah cool thank you yeah it's just you
know we do stuff differently we're the
weird ones
yup we do dave ramsey we stopped
drinking our hometown is a very blue
collar town it's a lot of drinking
everyone knows everyone but there's a
lot of great things that have come from
it like
my dad have got better in our
relationship we've got
i mean it's cheaper living so it's just
we pro and con this decision
back and forth back and forth and until
we're blue in the face and we just can't
decide if we're holding our family back
and our marriage back
or are we over dramatizing living in our
hometown it's not like
the worst place in the world but i don't
know
it's just a constant conversation in our
marriage
you are living on the polls
right and so i want to give you some
peace about the middle
you could move for a couple years and
try it out
and it's going to be no worse for wear
you've made your
decision in either or and life is just
too twisty and
wacky and weird for anything to really
ever be either or
and so um a couple of things to think
through
wherever you all move you two will go
with you
and so if your marriage has wonky things
that y'all need to work through if
you've got relational conflicts if your
sex life isn't what you thought it was
going to be
if you don't like how he
deals with kids homework or whatever
those same things are going to travel
with you
right so will all the free babysitting
that will go away
right um the other side of it is
if you have a very clear path of where
you want to go you say that you want
different lives you want to have a
different family tree you love your
family
you love them deeply i can hear it and
yet you want something more you want
something different
both of those things can be true at the
same time and both of those things can
be
just and right at the same time that's
all good
what i want you to do is be really
explicit about what you want to be
different
because you're going to chase a feeling
and that feeling will never show up for
you
you're going to assume after we've been
married for 15 years
and we're not drinking anymore and we're
out of debt that suddenly everything's
going to materialize and it doesn't work
like that
um you have to be able to know i want
both a beach vacation
and i need to understand that when i get
to the beach i'm still going to get
sunburned and i'm still going to get
itchy
from dirt right those two things are
both true
and most people have destinations and
dreams but they end up being just
feelings of what's going to be like when
i get on top of the pyramids in egypt
it's going to be hot right it's going to
be
hot and you're going to be tired it's
going to be when you get down and
reflect on the journey and what we did
right so
you got to know why you're moving what
what ex
specifically what's that picture of our
life we're going to look like and then
live into that
and then if you gotta move move you
gotta move move i
i left a few years ago left texas left
everything i know every friend i had
um every family member of mine lives in
texas
we're all everybody's there and yeah we
left
and my relationship with my family is
still super close i don't see them as
much anymore
we talk probably more often now and
i've made new great community here and
my family visits me and it's
wonderful and good um right do i miss
stuff yeah of course i do
and i've also found parts of me that i
never knew existed
which have been great so sometimes i
just feel
guilty too like our kids getting to
experience our grandparents
but then i i mean i i think i have a
good idea of why we want to be different
and what that means it's just a constant
and we had both had traumatic
childhoods and now we're living in the
hometown where all that trauma happened
and i had a
tragic incident happen in high school
and i don't know sometimes i feel like
i'm
swimming re-swimming in all of the
emotions all the time
so let me uh let me help
you 100 are
100 are and there's a good and a bad to
that
the bad is moving you're still gonna
have those experiences unless you go
deal directly head-on with that trauma
unless you get a good trauma counselor
and you work through that
the the good part is yeah some of that
trauma is
geographically located when you drive
down that same street and you go past
that same house
and you run into that same dude or that
same woman in the grocery store
you're just not going to do that right
if you live in arkansas right
it's not going to be there but that
clock
that scanner that's still trying to keep
you safe in the back of your heart and
mind
it's still going to be run in full blast
until you do the hard work of dealing
with those childhood traumas
so running running from it moving out
away
isn't going to solve that but it can
definitely let the alarms down a little
bit so you can do that healing work
i think the main thing i want you to do
bailey is to not live in either
live in next two to three years
okay and if you move away and you're you
want your kids to be
involved in your grandparents life keep
them involved in your grandparents life
instead of seeing them every single week
you're gonna see
once every three months for a week at a
time right the time will be batched and
it will be grouped together and about
day four you'll realize
this is why we moved and then you'll
leave and everybody will be good right
yeah and then if you move away and it
just sucks
move back right right i just
i didn't know if there's i was always
hoping like to
i don't i just don't want to move my
kids once they were established when
they're a little older we have a
three-year-old and a one-year-old
uh hey they're not established at all
they're three in one
they don't even know what day it is they
don't even know i think
i think i've told this this story on the
podcast but
my wife um she's a was a you know she
still is she's a brilliant scholar she
was
hired to come work at a school just
outside of sao paulo brazil
i took my son with me we were i was just
a trailer right i went
and my son and i had two weeks of just
glorious time together i mean
picking fruit off of a tree avocados off
trees like
on the street right two cans landing it
was it was
unbelievable it was like fantasy island
and he literally has absolutely no
memory of that whatsoever
it doesn't even exist and i thought we
were doing all these great bonding
moments and
when we're old dude he doesn't remember
any of that and he was two
three four somewhere around there so all
that to tell you is
they are going to be established when
you and your husband
love each other deeply y'all are
anchored in together kids are resilient
they will be good to go with you okay
and so it's you guys
being together relationally making a a
concrete decision let's go do this let's
just go move here's the deal i can hear
your voice you've already moved in your
heart
you just need permission to go so here's
your permission go right
um and be prepared one of those
grandparents may pass away as soon as
you move
that happened to us one of those
grandparents may get
really angry with you one of those
grandparents may get
super super jealous and wish they had
gone to
any number of things can happen and any
number of those things that happen
doesn't make your move wrong
doesn't make your fresh start wrong i
just want you and your husband to be
really clear super crystal clear as to
why you're going and where you're headed
what's your relationship going to look
like what are your values going to look
like
what are you going to do whether that's
going to a marriage therapist
a getting a community together a good
group of friends what's that going to
look like that's going to get you to
those values it's going to get you to
that new family tree that y'all
y'all are planting and you're nourishing
and good for you guys good for you
that's so
cool all right um bailey you just made
my whole day